whoa we're back at it again it's Greg
and John Jonas's named Greg as my name
our parents names are different if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today become a reject get that
out of the way why wait till the end of
the video Resident Evil the final
chapter short known in what comes after
this
yeah just linking okay so Resident Evil
the final chapter I haven't seen a
Resident Evil movie since part 3 yeah we
saw it together we Universal CityWalk
and it's kind of a cool movie 2007 I
really lost interest and keeping up with
it they don't hook me and it's they're
not close enough to the video games to
really injuries meaning this is the
franchise that comes out like in the
background of my life yeah still making
them there's still a fan base yeah and I
enjoyed the first movie but but yeah
after that I just yeah Paul WS Anderson
man I don't know what you'd do what's is
weird is he making amazing films totally
used in the system with amazing work
ever so shocked Pompey there will be
blood the master Boogie Nights inherent
vice and Harun no that was okay I liked
in here play this is no mortal kombat
but yeah I'm watching this cuz there's
so many requests to watch this clearly
I'm Suzy astok about it hey maybe
they'll finally incorporate some and me
is just Java little [ __ ] Paul WS
Anderson wife is an amazing actress too
can be fifth element last great role I
remember heard
get that Suicide Squad five field
machinery
we're gonna being yet effects going on
it
how to get out of Raccoon City man
humanity will cease to exist
enough to return to the heart everything
is led to this
what we're gonna do you're gonna kill
every last one
yeah
the built-up returns
Oh Oh get your lasers the first movie
I think we guests want us to say is
badass looks like a [ __ ] ton of fun but
I can I can't help but feel any time I
see a Resident Evil trailer the
potential that has been missed out on
with this whole franchise yeah hopefully
this is the final chapter I thought like
two movies ago is the final chapter what
do they do they did epochal extinction
of poggle is like every subtitle is the
world yeah yeah I'm like next we're just
gonna be a new book what I gotta say
though is that whenever I watched the
Resident Evil movies even though I only
seen the first three whatever actual
zombie show up I think is kind of cool
yeah I just I'm just a fan of the zombie
genre I grew up on zombie flicks so
anytime there's a zombie I'm like oh or
when they mix in like one of the
creatures from the games like these
movies follow a weird pattern where it
seems like every other one they try to
put a bunch of game [ __ ] and it is
apocalypse has like nemesis and a whole
bunch of other things are not a part
whatever the second one is the other a
word and so I'm curious about how
they're what they're gonna do here
whether they're gonna have a bunch of
zombie stuff or you know keep it I doubt
it
I really feel like zombies are the last
thing on the Resident Evil franchise
like this is this is one of those
properties where I'm like I really love
those games and like there's a lot to
drop you don't have to go with the story
but there's a lot to draw from in terms
of you know places and creatures in
mythology and they kind of do there's
something about the the tambour of these
movies and a look in the field that I
just don't love like I kind of like
Alice and everything else just feels
like a you know just kind of like a
hollow be great action movie that I've
seen done better yeah I mean this looks
like it's inspired by any kind of end of
the world
[ __ ] yeah there's an evil fury road like
it got a lot of these similar touches in
there but I mean what the franchise
currently offers they've given us a
major sci-fi picture yeah like that's
what they've they went over they steered
away from zombie horror film into sci-fi
a crazy sci-fi action story which I
guess works for its own job clearly
there's a fan base for it I
I don't know if the fan base is just
Resident Evil game fans to keep hoping
the movies you'll be good or if they're
actually just like fans of the movie
that really like these films people who
like the movies and hey I guess you like
I do think me liova which is cool as
Alice like I'm always like I wish they
would just make a decision after a while
because sometimes when they try to put a
bunch of game characters in it doesn't
really coalesce and the thing is like
these movies aren't exactly for me so
I'm not thrilled by this trailer like
this trailer kind of says we're out of
ideas to me because it's like we're
going back to the Red Queen and the hive
which were kind of barely as well that
laser go save the franchise are going
out at a big bang a little red girl from
before us they're waiting to see her
again
you know John this might be the movie
that goes back to the beginning kind of
like Dark Knight Rises and then you're
like oh wow it's all tied in this makes
I don't move wants better to be all tied
I wanted it all to be tied in now all to
meet intertwine interconnected and I
hope we get spin-offs yeah yeah I hope
that that happens Carlos Olivera movie
let's do it the sad thing is the
Resident Evil video game the first one
is significantly shot better than any of
these there's something giving Paul the
Rio Sanders and more and more money to
make these and everyone I see like three
is kind of cool I guess but every piece
I see out of one of these just looks
like it's more expensive and somehow
shinier I remember playing the first
game and I'm just being very much
admired by its visual style like how
there'd be one shot you walk out of
frame into the next shot into the next
shot and then so sometimes you walk to
another shot bassam be there you go but
well that's the troll is like especially
when they remade the first game and they
remastered it for for Gamecube and they
up to the graphics and all that stuff
like they really made it cinematic and I
feel like that kind of hurts if you're a
fan of Resident Evil that kind of hurts
these movies cos you're like I've seen
this play out like a movie before yeah
and it's not this movie yeah because
it's like they it's kind of it's typical
visual styles and there's nothing
visually that looks that unique in terms
of its stylistic imagery granted I can't
listen like this together but yeah still
it's like from what I
scene Studios that per the same studios
that produced that washed out gray brown
color palette it looks like the last
survivors and I mean you guys probably
heard of that movie bigger lot survivors
and it looks like this with trying to
get a more of a budget to try to look
like Mad Max fury road with some zombies
in there and then some human villains
and then it's just all over the place
and then yeah like their monster this
could be a really good franchise it
could be and I'd be like a great film
franchise yeah the only thing that gives
me hope for this is there are a certain
amount of people who do like resident
evil 3 and that's the one that's all out
in the desert in Vegas and stuff like
that and I feel like a return to the
desert could be cool and just this this
trailer feels like a trailer like it's
it's it's ironic music and I look at all
this [ __ ] action that well this is
these shows are lies though we've seen
the Resident Evil movie zippers they
look they look cool and fun in the
trailers whether you watch them and they
just they take themselves so seriously
it's like they the people behind them
think they're making like it's like the
the first few Fast & Furious films it's
just a little worse like yeah they think
they're making great films and then they
realize this is not that great
yeah they just embrace the cheese in the
bag yeah if they had a little actual fun
there was some self-awareness my cheesy
this is it could do better and maybe it
maybe for some people part of the charm
is the lack of self-aware about every
Resident Evil movie I see just kind of
feels like a bargain bin movie with some
shiny effects on it and like the acting
is always all over the place the effects
are kinda all over the blades trailers
show shiny effects but then the movie 2
also tends to deliver some pretty bad
effects of times too yeah well you know
it's like I appreciate the ambition but
hey like a lot of this movie looks like
it's gonna be outside in the desert
under blistering Sun and that's a hard
place to do to hide like you can hide CG
in shadows and work with your budget but
all about ambition
remember Rudy he got shot before the
game yeah that's what happened couldn't
never play football
straight out of the University of Notre
Dame
we already said subscribe I already says
names John Jesus Jerry facebook.com
slash blue Mouse basically that calms
that's too real rejects I don't like
really promoting all these social
network stuff it just is too much
talking and I get bored repeating the
same thing over and over again shout out
to me achieve other than if it and I
hope her and Paul WS Anderson have
beautiful kids but don't lose that body
and don't get divorced cousin Peter Berg
and and what's-her-name from the
underworld movies Kate Beckinsale yeah
are they getting divorced
yep and sale wasn't married a Peter
Bergen what she yeah yeah like there's a
whole summer job sub-sect of dudes make
movies like psycho formations there why
a Beckinsale was married to the guy who
did underworld oh yeah yeah who did
underworld sorry whoever the director of
general I don't know heater burgers
Peter Berg's done other action movies
right he just like Hancock in the run
down there you know
all right got your embarrassment on this
channel okay well this god you're there
that same mode of like you know action
Jordan didn't he do he also had a he did
total Rico starring role in collateral
really Peter Bergen yeah I don't know
one of the cops Len Wiseman there you go
yeah same name I see it again wise well
there are you James